Justin and Hailey Bieber are opening up
about their marriage for the first time
in the March 2019 issue of Baja they're
so cute the story is so good the couple
is getting candid like never before and
we're here to break down these things
biggest things we learned it's a lot and
they're huge yeah ready for you guys
justin admits that the reason they got
married so quickly is because they
wanted to have sex makes sense yeah get
to that altar in fact Justin had been
celibate for over a year before they
reconnected last June and says he had
what he calls a legitimate problem with
sex so we know a lot of you guys
probably thinks that the celibacy was
actually a religious decision but Justin
doesn't consider himself religious no
quote that confuses a lot of people
because they're like well you go to
church I believe in the story of Jesus
that's the simplicity of what I believe
but I don't believe in all the religious
elitism and pretentiousness I get
sensitive when religion comes up because
it's been so hurtful to a lot of people
JB also gets candid about his depression
and his past drug use and this is where
we learn even more about why he stopped
having sex he says at one point he
considered himself quote super
promiscuous he added I think I used an X
because I was so ashamed my mom always
said to treat women with respect for me
that was always in my head while I was
doing it so I could never enjoy it drugs
put a screen between me and what I was
doing it got pretty dark I think there
were times when my security was coming
in late at night to check my pulse and
see if I was still breathing
yikes and the bombshells don't stop
there remember we are only halfway
through the couple also admits to having
a major falling out after they first
dated three years ago Haley says quote
negative things happen that we still
need to talk about and work through
fizzled would not be the right word it
was more like a very dramatic
excommunication there was a period where
if I walked into a room he would walk
out that said I know that's jr. yes
these are you dying to know what
happened yes a lot of an excerpt
magazine cover and it is refreshing to
hear how honest they're being about
during the war
canaveri right and they admit you know
look we're very young
this is tough and I appreciate knowing
that I feel like they're gonna last
because you're so self aware of their
relationship and they're saying what
everyone is thinking so at least they
know and they're putting in the work
yeah I like it agree and get this Justin
talks about buying into his own height
in the past but one person who was never
a crazed believer was hailey she says
quote I was never a super fan of him or
of anyone I didn't think about it in any
kind of way except for the fact that he
was cute over time he became my best guy
friend I was running around with him as
his homey but we weren't hanging out
romantically I like that though they
were friends first Yeah right
building the foundation yeah this
sweetest takeaway from this whole
interview though is how dedicated they
both seem to making this marriage work
and they understand it's not always easy
hailey says quote it's just that I'm
fighting to do this the right way to
build a healthy relationship I want
people to know that we're coming from a
really genuine place but were two young
people who are learning as we go I'm not
going to sit here and lie and say it's
all a magical fantasy it's always going
to be hard it's a choice we're going to
change a lot but we're committed to
growing together and supporting each
other and those changes that's how I
look at it at the end of the day - he's
my best friend I never get sick of him
one more tidbit for you guys do not
expect any baby Bieber's anytime soon
they say that they are waiting a few
years for that chapter probably smart
and if you want one more reason to swoon
Justin calls Haley his baby boo and says
she's logical and structured and the
security he needs I'm dying I know you
good this is one of my favorite reads of
the year you guys should totally check
it out it's all up on vogue comm but we
want to know what you thought of the
interview what was your biggest takeaway
let us know and of course be sure to
subscribe to all things et until next
time I'm Katie underscore Kraus and I'm
at Halle underscore Stephens bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]